brutal Falls shocking twists and the
moment that broke all the rules of the
franchise these screamed six scenes or
stick with viewers for a long time to
come
ever since a cold shock of the opening
moments of the original scream fans have
known that it's never too early for
characters played by big name actors to
be killed off in one of these films
after all in a no master Janet Lee's
premature departure in Alfred
Hitchcock's Psycho the original Craven
directed phenomenon open with the
gruesome death of Casey Becker played by
the film's most recognizable star at the
time Drew Barrymore in typical slasher
style most films in the franchise have
since opened with a murder but it's
actually been a while since our Scream
movie began with the death of one of its
advertised Stars Jada Pinkett's Maureen
was murdered in the teaser to Scream 2
back in 1997. andalie F schreiber's
cartoon weary was knocked off in the
opening of 2000's scream 3. subverting
expectations Scream 4 began with a
series of meta misleads before finally
giving the audience's first two kills
and Jenna Ortega's character actually
survived the first ghost face attack in
2022 scream there's certain rules to
surviving a stat movie
believe me I know Scream 6 for its parts
appears to play this expectation
straight when it introduces Samara
weaving's Professor Laura crane only for
her to be murdered before the opening
titles crane stabbing in a Manhattan
Alleyway is violent and upsetting but
this alone wouldn't necessarily shock a
season scream fan this time around
however the Killer's identity is
revealed immediately and it's quite
surprising college student Jason Carvey
portrayed by Tom Holland's Spider-Man
co-star Tony Revo Laurie what's up this
twist is only setting up the next one as
Jason is dispatched shortly thereafter
by the film's True Villain and just like
that two of the faces on the poster have
been dispensed with and the film isn't
even 10 minutes in much like the
original screams opening twist such
moves put the audience off balance from
the very beginning it's still keeping
with the spirits of Hitchcock who was so
famously devoted to his psycho secret
that he wouldn't let people enter the
theater after the movie began
Scream 6 establishes Chad the hunky
sweetheart as a romantic foil to Terror
this feels like a Twist in itself as the
two characters don't get to spend much
time together in the first film where
they're fighting for their lives even so
actors Mason Gooding and Jenna Ortega
share enough chemistry that is easy to
get on board this particular ship after
all it's been ages since scream
introduced a new romantic relationship
between lead characters Gail weathers
and Dewey Reilly were on and off for
five films it's about time two of these
Woodsbury teams got together after their
first attempt at aches has interrupted
early in the film the pair once again
becomes too busy fending off Ghost Face
attacks to make another that is until
the third act when they finally
capitalize on a quiet moment while
waiting for Ghostface to step into a
trap they set up at the Killer's secret
lair Chad and Terror share a tender kiss
after the kiss Chad gets shanked in the
side several more times buying Terror
time to escape this appears to be the
end for Chad and it's pretty shocking
though not as Glory as a lots of the
film's other chaos the reason for this
restraint is probably because it is not
in fact a kill for the second
consecutive movie Chad appears to be
stubbed to death but is eventually
carted out of the crime scene on a
gurney miraculously clinging to life
which takes some of the bite out of the
scene
Scream 6 gives its viewers plenty of
notice that Legacy characters on The
Chopping Block resident horror nerd
Mindy makes a point of telling the crew
that's in the franchise film they're
living through the Old Guard is
basically just here to get killed the
killer gives Gale the same warning over
the phone when he calls her for the very
first time in the franchise which itself
feels like an omen that a story has come
to its conclusion there's never been one
like me Gail still nothing quite
prepares a viewer for the violent shock
of seeing a beloved character murdered
ghosts face invades Gale's Manhattan
apartment and quickly disposes of her
boyfriend Brooks after putting up an
impressive fight nearly outsmarting the
killer Gail is pinned down on the floor
and stabbed in the gut some Carpenter
arrives to chase off ghost face before
he can do any more damage but the event
has an undeniable era of finality to it
this moment would likely rank higher on
the list if audiences didn't learn at
the end of the film that Gail has
survived the encounter Gale has cheated
to death before even walking off a
bullet and scream 2. birds are encounter
with Ghostface and scream 6 feels
visceral and final when it happens
turning out to be yet another false
alarm the scene will probably lose much
of its intensity and Effectiveness on
repeat viewings
some Carpenter said the new series
heroine introduced in the fifth scream
film has a Darkness inside her the
Secret Door to of original Ghostface
Billy Loomis Sam is haunted by visions
of her murderous father and has
apparently inherited his predisposition
towards violence what's the matter
Sydney you look like you've seen a ghost
she keeps a handle on herself through
medication and mental discipline but
she's got a vicious streak that comes
out when she's under pressure viewers
first saw her cut loose at the end of
2022 scream when she repeatedly stabbed
her murderous boyfriend Richie in the
brutal fashion typically employed by
Ghostface in Scream 6 some struggles to
cope with a sense of satisfaction she
felt while butchering Richie while being
accused of being the real 2022 Ghost
Face by conspiracy theorists on the
internet the online rumors turn out to
be part of a scheme engineered by
Richie's father detective Wayne Bailey
whose end goal is to frame Sam as the
new ghost face bayley traps Sam in a
secret Ghost Face Museum that Richie
curated before his death whose artifacts
include them basketball by every
previous Ghostface throughout the film's
climax Bailey urges Sam to put on the
mask of Billy Loomis and fulfill her
Destiny by dying in it surprisingly some
eventually does choose to put on her
father's mask for only as long as it
takes to kill Bailey Ghost Face style
stabbing him multiple times in the face
and abdomen it's the bizarre and
effective twist and quite unnerving
the scream Series has always offered
transparency in wearing its rules on its
sleeve there is always a Randy or Mindy
type to tell viewers what can and can't
happen and to define the danger the
characters find themselves in typically
whoever's behind the ghost face mask is
trying to reproduce the experience of
being the villain in a slasher flick
which makes him dangerous but also
predictable to some extent you mean like
a Halloween
no not like in Halloween oh
throughout the run of the franchise
scream has had an unspoken rule when
you're wearing the ghost face mask
you're only allowed to wield a knife the
only times a Ghost Face Killer has
pulled a gun were after their identity
has been revealed never before something
about the visual would feel unnatural
like Jason Voorhees holding a shotgun or
Captain America grabbing a chainsaw in
Scream 6 however the new ghost face does
indeed break them all during salmon
Terrace first confrontation with him on
the streets of Manhattan the Carpenters
seek shelter in a bodega where the
shopkeeper attempts to defend his store
with a shotgun whereas previous Killers
might have stabbed the gunman and thrown
the firearm away this ghost face has no
problem with stealing the weapon and
proceeding to shoot up the place footage
of a gun toting Ghostface scandalized
Scream fans on social media from the
moment it first appeared in the trailers
and there's no less weird seeing it on
the contacts of the film the sense of
danger around the familiar movie monster
is immediately increased at least for
the duration of this sequence luckily
for the protagonist ghosts face more or
less follows the usual rules for the
rest of the film
as viewers catch up with Mindy Meeks
Martin in the beginning of Scream 6
she's a college freshman lounging at a
frat party with a new girlfriend Annika
Annika is immediately cool and likable
based on previous Scream movies this
means one of two things she's secretly
the killer or she's not long for this
world sadly Annika receives perhaps the
most brutal death of Scream 6 when
ghosts faced invade salmon Terrace
Apartments while the rest of the gang is
visiting after Ghostface appears to
murder their roommate Quinn the
survivors are forced to flee the
apartment by crawling out of a bedroom
window and Crossing to a neighbor's
place via a narrow ladder over a gap
several stories high Annika is the last
across the Gap already badly wounded by
ghostface's knife by the time she gets
halfway across ghost's face is broken
into the bedroom and taken hold of the
ladder shaking it violently until Annika
loses her grip plummeting to the
concrete below the film then offers a
close-up on her gnarly bashed in head
most of the Scream 6 victims and targets
are slasher film veterans able to keep
themselves together throughout the
violence but this is annika's first
encounter with a mass killer so her
terrified and desperate reaction is much
closer to your average innocent horror
movie victim it's par for the course in
a horror movie but the fact that she's
the only character who gets a prolonged
screaming death in Scream 6 makes it hit
home
in a slasher film is a necessity that
some moments need to be visually
upsetting to viewers and that others
need to be triumphant and cathartic for
the Killer's surviving victims however
one of the leaves of the rebooted scream
franchise is Sam Carpenter who wrestles
with some truly psychotic impulses and
her capacity for cruelty is a bit beyond
the average audience's comfort level
during the final confrontation with the
three new ghostfaces who turn out to be
the late Richie Kershaw's surviving
family some shoots her treacherous
roommates Quinn in the head right in
front of her father detective Wayne
Bailey some kills Quinn in self-defense
but the figurative Twist of the knife
comes when Sam has a goal to smirk about
it or standing face to face with Bailey
while Bailey is a serial killer there's
something shocking about the film's hero
relishing in the pain of a guy who's
just watched his last two Offspring die
violent death Sydney Prescott and Gail
weathers could be pretty good throws
they even set a teenager on fire and
Scream 5 but Sam is on another level
without question the greatest cinematic
Triumph of Scream 6 is in the tooth
grindingly tense Subway sequence in
which some Terror Chad and Dany Brave
along subway ride crowded with costume
strangers celebrating Halloween some of
whom are even dressed as Ghostface in a
protracted mostly wordless sequence the
heroes attempt to keep an eye on anyone
who might turn out to be a threat an
impossible task as passengers are being
shuffled about at each stop the killer
could be anyone finally Mindy finds
herself cornered at the end of a subway
car and gets stabbed in the abdomen by
one of the Ghostface Killers or the
dozens of strangers around her remain
oblivious slasher movies often play on
the fear of being caught alone and
unaware but the subway sequence in
Scream 6 speaks to an even more terrible
nightmare like the murder of Maureen in
the packed movie theater in Scream 2
Mindy's Subway stabbing forces of
viewers to acknowledge that one can face
mortal danger even with countless people
around to witness it of course like so
many of the other disturbing sequences
in Scream 6 this one would feel
weightier if Mindy didn't recover from
her injuries by the end of the film
while many viewers will be thrilled that
Mindy was not a casualty of the
bloodiest scream to date and sure is
weird that so little of the film's
violence proves fatal
[Music]
thank you